how boost up is your twitter account how
many people are you paying to boost your
twitter account a lot that's a yeah I'd
say I say that you have a lot of Twitter
followers Rosco tweets 750 times a day
most of them are two single character
tweets like an N or a pee but he stole
more like something on yeah sometimes
you get that yeah I think that that that
a lot of actors out there are really
great self-promoters and directors and
things like that and I think that that's
great you know I mean if that's how if
they feel like that's how they need
their to help their careers that's
fantastic i hope that that doesn't
become the norm you know and i hope that
that doesn't I mean you know it's
business well correct me if I'm wrong
like just to get back to what we're
talking about before it doesn't a
certain amount of self-promotion turn
you off like don't you think the best
for my self promotion is making good
stuff and that when you when you have a
certain friend you know we all need to
mention names or anything but friend X
or something every time he does anything
you get a text saying like Joey I'm so
proud of this movie I may please come
out and support please turn into CBS at
9pm to watch this come to my arch or
whatever and it's always sort of
mediocre stuff don't you kind of just
look at it and kind of disregard it
eventually and think like oh god all
this guy does because I always rattling
so I I don't know see I I think that the
best form of promotion is good work and
then you know I oh I feel like there's
got to be a lot of people who feel like
me and feel like you about this that
when self-promotion is kind of a turnoff
it makes me it takes a sort of a notch
off my desire to sort of be a spectator
with whatever they're sort of trying to
shove down my throat I I feel like sort
of you know
letting the work speak for itself is one
of the more appealing things about about
an artist or anybody who's in the
entertainment business whether they're
an artist or not making good work is is
great and if somebody's really trying to
force me to see their work it makes me
suspicious about how good the work and
possibly be yeah but I think also even
now it was beyond the work and it's
about people kind of letting others in
their lives you know yeah that's all I
rather tweeting and then sing like lon
you know just got out of the guitar
store I'm gonna go play my guitar now at
the gym and then all these like like
tweeners or like oh my god he plays a
guitar you know it's it's it has nothing
to do with their that's really I'm
worried because I was just writing I
play the guitar because I just wanted
people to know you know I wasn't
necessarily writing for all those
tweeners look up what I tell you really
nice that response just always great
you